>>> RON DeSANTIS IS IN ROAD TEST
MODE, SELLING HIS BIG MIDTERM
RE-ELECTION WIN AS A MODEL FOR
THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND THERE IS NO QUESTION A LOT
OF REPUBLICAN LEADERS, DONORS,
OPERATIVES AND VOTERS ARE
IMPRESSED.
BUT THERE'S ALSO SOME CLEAR AND
INTERESTING GRUMBLING.
THE 44-YEAR-OLD FLORIDA GOVERNOR
HAS A GO IT ALONE REPUTATION,
AND A CLEAR DISDAIN OR DISTRUST
OF THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT.
DeSANTIS RECEIVED A STANDING
OVATION THIS PAST WEEKEND AFTER
SPEAKING TO A REPUBLICAN
GATHERING IN LAS VEGAS THAT
ATTRACTED MORE THAN A HALF DOZEN
POTENTIAL 2024 PROSPECTS.
BUT ONE ATTENDEE DELIVERED A
COMPLAINT AND A COMPLIMENT.
TELLING CNN WHEN DeSANTIS CAME
ON, ALL THE KIDS CAME UP, BUT HE
DIDN'T STICK AROUND TO SCHMOOZE.
IS THIS JUST DONORS, OPERATIVES,
THEY WANT TO BE LOVED, THEY WANT
TO SCHMOOZE?
IS IT LIKE SO WHAT?
THIS IS SOME EGOS THAT WANT TO
BE STROKED BY RON DeSANTIS, OR
DOES HE HAVE A PROBLEM?
>> THIS IS YES AND.
RON DeSANTIS IS A ROCK STAR YOU
SAW THE RECEPTION, SHAKING HANDS
ON THE ROPE LINE.
AT AN EVENT LAST WEEK AT THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR ASSOCIATION
MEETING IN ORLANDO, HE GAVE A
SPEECH, HAD A CONVERSATION, A
BIG STANDING OVATION, AND LOOK,
HE'S GOT A LOT GOING FOR HIM.
HE HAS OVER $200 MILLION IN THE
BANK.
POLLING SHOWS IF ANYBODY IS
GOING TO CHALLENGE DONALD TRUMP
FOR THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION,
IT'S HIM.
BUT THESE DONORS ARE POINTING
OUT THAT HE DOES SEEM TO HAVE A
DISDAIN, AS YOU PUT IT, FOR THE
GLAD HANDING THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IN THIS MOMENT IN THE
PRIMARY PROCESS.
HE DOES NOT LIKE TO MEET WITH
DO
DONORS.
THE MEETING IN HIS HOME STATE HE
WENT TO ONE EVENT.
HE WASN'T AT A RECEPTION WITH
DONORS AND THEY NOTICE AND
PICKING UP ON IT.
IT IS A QUESTION OF WHETHER OR
NOT HE CAN GET THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION WITHOUT DOING THAT.
THAT'S BEEN HIS MO THROUGHOUT
HIS POLITICAL CAREER BUT HE
HASN'T REALLY BEEN ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE THE WAY HE SEEMS
TO BE MOVING TOWARDS NOW.
>> HE'S BEING PICKED APART LIKE
A TURKEY RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE HE
IS THIS RISING STAR AND BECAUSE
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T
WANT TRUMP THINK WE MIGHT HAVE
TO PICK ONE PERSON TO RALLY
AROUND.
CHRIS CHRISTIE SAYS I DON'T
THINK RON HANGS OUT WITH
ANYBODY.
DAVE JOLLY CALLS RON DeSANTIS A
BIT OF AN ODD DUCK.
RYAN COSTELLO SAID HE HAD
FRIENDS, ALLIES BUT HE WAS NOT A
BACKSLAPPER.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES THAT
MATTER?
WE WERE TALKING DURING THE
BREAK.
BARACK OBAMA WAS SORT OF ALOOF.
I THINK HE SERVED TWO TERMS AS
PRESIDENT.
>> I COVERED BARACK OBAMA FOR
EIGHT YEARS PLUS HIS CAMPAIGN.
HE WAS ALOOF.
THERE WERE WHITE HOUSE EVENTS
WHERE PEOPLE WERE INVITED HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO SHAKE HANDS HE GOT
CRITICIZED FOR NOT STAYING AT
THE EVENT THERE, LET ALONE
FUND-RAISERS FOR THE
DENUCLEDNC AND HIS
CAMPAIGN.
HE DID FINE.
IT'S OKAY TO BE ALOOF IF THAT'S
WHO YOU ARE.
BUT AT THE BEGINNING OF A
NATIONAL CAREER ON THE POLITICAL
STAGE, NO DOUBT THAT REPORTING
IS FASCINATING.
IT ALSO SHOWS THAT THERE'S A
TARGET ON HIS BACK.
>> SO YOU QUOTE THIS DeSANTIS
FUND-RAISER IN YOUR PIECE, NO
ONE SEEMS TO CARE IF HE WANTS TO
STAY AT A RECEPTION AND SHAKE
HANDS THEY CARE WHAT HE DOES AS
GOVERNOR TO IMPROVE THEIR LIVES
ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
THIS WAS THE OBAMA MAGIC IF YOU
WILL, HE COULD HOLD THE
ESTABLISHMENT ASIDE BECAUSE HE
WAS WINNING.
IF THEY THINK YOU'RE THE HORSE
GETTING THEM WHAT THEY WANT,
WHICH IS THE WHITE HOUSE, PEOPLE
WILL GRUMBLE BUT SEND A CHECK.
>> DeSANTIS CAME UP THROUGH THE
TEA PARTY ERA AGAIN AND THEN
SORT OF EMBARRASSED THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS AND THEN WAS IN THE TRUMP
WING OF THE PARTY.
ALL OF THAT MEANS YOU ENTERED
THE POLITICS IN A DEFENSIVE
CROUCH KIND OF.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DEAL WITH
THE ESTABLISHMENT BECAUSE YOU'RE
AN OUTSIDER.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE AN
INSIDER?
A GOVERNOR RUNNING FOR ELECTION
LIKE ANY OTHER GOVERNOR.
NOW YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IF YOU
DON'T WANT THE ESTABLISHMENT,
THE BRASESTABLISHMENT INFRASTRUE
AND THAT'S THE MONEY AND THE
GLAD HANDERS AND DONORS AND
MAKING THOSE TASTE MAKERS AND
KING MAKERS HAPPY.
TRUMP HAS CAPTURED SO MUCH OF
THE STATE PARTY MECHANISM AROUND
THE COUNTRY THAT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT DeSANTIS' LANE IS THROUGH
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE STATE
PARTIES, YOU'RE NOT DOING YOUR
HAND SHAKES WITH THE DONORS.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE YOU GET?
MAYBE YOU HAVE THE ANSWER.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
THAT IS THE QUESTION, A CONCERN.
YOU NEED FRIENDS IF YOU'RE IN
RON DeSANTIS' POSITION.
THAT'S SOMETHING I HEAR, WILL HE
HAVE ENOUGH FRIENDS.
HE'S NOT BUDDY BUDDY WITH THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS.
>> AND THE BASE IS GIVING TRUMP
ALL THE SMALL DONATIONS.
HE'S NOT TAPPING THAT YET.
>> HE HAS OVER $200 MILLION IN
THE BANK.
HE HAS MONEY AND HE HAS A BASE
OF SUPPORT.
BUT THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS,
HE'S UNDER THE MICROSCOPE IN A
LOT OF WAYS.
THERE'S AN EAGERNESS TO GET ON
BOARD WITH DeSANTIS AMONG DONORS
I SPEAK WITH.
THEY WANT TO KNOW MORE AND SO
FAR THEY'RE GETTING HALFWAY.
>> WE'RE IN THE ERA OF THE
BILLION DOLLAR CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS HOW YOUR TABLE STAKES
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> UNTIL THEY HAD TO, THE
REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT DIDN'T
WANT TRUMP, PUSHED HIM AWAY,
HE'S NOT ONE OF US, DIDN'T SHARE
OUR PRINCIPLES, OUR PARTY, THE
ESTABLISHMENT DOESN'T LIKE THEM,
BUT HE HAS THE DONOR, BASE, AND
NO TRUMP STATES ON TRUMP'S SIDE.
LET'S LISTEN TO DeSANTIS.
YOU MIGHT NOT LOVE EVERYTHING
ABOUT ME, MY RECORD, I CAN WIN.
>> WE'VE SHOWN IN FLORIDA IS YOU
CAN STAND UP FOR TRUTH, YOU CAN
STAND ON PRINCIPLE, YOU CAN
FIGHT THE WOKE ELITE, AND YOU
CAN WIN.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN EVER FIND
A GOVERNOR IN HISTORY THAT HAS
BEEN ATTACKED MORE THAN ME FOR
STANDING UP FOR WHAT'S TRUE.
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED MORE OVER A
FOUR-YEAR PERIOD THAN ANYBODY
THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THIS, WE'VE
GOT A LOT MORE TO DO.
AND I HAVE ONLY BEGUN TO FIGHT.
>> THERE IS A TRUMP-Y MESSAGE TO
THAT.
GO AFTER THE WOKE PEOPLE, THE
MEDIA.
>> ALSO THE ONLY I CAN --
>> ONLY I.
BUT HE ESSENTIALLY COMES TO THE
TABLE WITH I HAVE MORE THAN 10%
OF THE VOTES TO BECOME
PRESIDENT, I HAVE FLORIDA, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
>> HE DOES BRING A LOT OF
TRUMP-Y ELEMENTS WITHOUT BEING
TRUMP ITSELF WHICH IS WHY IF YOU
TALK TO REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T
LIKE TRUMP THEY CAN BE OPEN TO
SUPPORTING GR
SUPPORTING GOVERNOR DeSANTIS.
THE FACT THAT HE WON
RESOUNDINGLY IS CERTAINLY A PLUS
IN HIS FAVOR.
>> IT HELPS EVERYBODY.
>> HE HAD A WEAK OPPONENT BUT HE
STILL WON.
IN THE END IT GOES IN THE BAOOK
AS A WIN.